we are here to document the lives of
people living in Alaska the harsh
reality is the environment we're up
against it makes it tough to do our job
they're working on life below zero can
be very dangerous guns here cameras here
never know what to expect you see that
gonna be tough but we're gonna get the
shot every scenario we got to prepare
for this we're still smiling or having
fun still making like below zero yeah
bring it on it's 9:00 a.m. day five of
our extended stay here at Chandalar I'm
still waiting for a weather window to
get a plane in here this beautiful blue
sky here but the area in between here
and where we need to get to is the
problem we're wrapped but 13 days
without plumbing or or heat everyday
I've thought including today I thought
there was a really good chance we would
get out messaging back and forth via
satellite to to the office and you know
they're doing our best their best to
keep us safe so I appreciate that and we
just got to wait until things are safe
to get out what can you do man makes
plans and God laughs
so this is our gear pile staged on the
beach ready to go if we get the call
that the plane is coming in we're just
gonna leave this out unless the weather
gets really bad run pretty low on food
it's definitely getting to the point
where we're scraping by some peanut
butter this could come in handy
a couple of cans of sardines that's
about it probably at about two or three
days of food left we moved into Glenn
sod house it's got an open door and then
a hole in the roof dragged our tarp over
here to kind of close up the roof hole a
little bit to keep a bit more the heat
in we'd set up cots would just barely
fit in the open space in there that's
been pretty great little home so here's
our door keep the heat in at night it
takes a little bit of gymnastics to get
out in the middle of the night without
making a lot of noise and waking up your
mates but it keeps the heat in really
well we need some wood to keep our sod
house warm we don't want to burn all
Glenn's wood so we're gonna go out into
the forest and get something it'll keep
us warm later and it'll warm us up right
now and give us something to do well you
want a standing dead tree so you're
looking for one that doesn't have any
green needles on it doesn't seem like
it's green at all it seems like it's
dead we can try for that one I think we
could take that down I think it'd be fun
guys a human be ver
starting to have a little concern about
it falling the other way we'll see what
happens yeah I think it wants to go the
other way it's almost ready to go Tony
[Music]
yeah firewood so now that we've dropped
this tree on the ground we need to cut
it up into manageable pieces we're about
a quarter mile from the sod house right
here so I'm gonna have to just carry
them on our shoulders we don't want to
cut them too big we don't want to cut
them too small because that means more
cuts and more trips so we'll just take a
guess at what the right length is and
cut it up into some chunks
[Music]
for sure you know what they say Tony
wood warms you twice we've got the tree
cut up into four usable chunks that I
think we can manage to carry out of here
on our own
so we'll do true trips we'll throw them
up on our shoulders walk them out
[Music]
[Applause]
did y'all how that was fun you know
[Music]
colder every night and having all this
wood is a killer thing to do not only is
it like it's keeping us warm in here for
one thing for sure but just having
something to do is trapped in this sort
of weird limbo that we're in you know
waiting waiting waiting for a new
message from production a new message
from our friends or family and just
trying to find something to do in the
meantime to fill time one of my favorite
things about spending extended period of
time out in the backcountry is it really
gives you an appreciation for all the
things that we can kind of take for
granted food is a huge part of that for
the crew I'm very very excited it smells
amazing
[Music]
you